وزارة التربية الوطنية
شرق
شريك في هذا المشروع
يمكننا أن نستحضر هنا بعد عام تقريبًا
اغتيال صموئيل عانينا
كل منزعج
[موسيقى]
أنا مدير قسم يانيك
الفنون الإسلامية في متحف اللوفر
والمفوض العام لهذا
فنون التشغيل الوطنية للإسلام واحد
مرت لي هدية
التفاعل بشري و
على قيد الحياة
المجتمع البشري الوحيد الذي عليه
يصمم القصة الفردية
التي تتكون منها 4 مهما كان
مستوى
المعلومات المعرفية
من الحساسية لذلك نحن هنا من أجل
نتحدث معًا ثم للمشاهدة
مجموعة من الأشياء أستطيع أن أقول اثنين
أشياء عن الإسلام الذين عرفوها
السكان الإسلاميون في وقت مبكر من
العصور الوسطى أو ولكن أيضًا
2 ـ الحداثة
أنا
قتال في sapinette
على متن السفينة أخيرًا لا نفوت كثيرًا
ولكن إذا احتوت الابتسامة على
17 قتيلا هناك القوى العاملة لدينا
[موسيقى]